[Music]
baby backs
my powers will become yours
[Applause]
[Music]
that's crazy right what are your
superpowers superpowers dude I don't
even know how to pee in this thing
hyperspeed I'd like to purchase some of
your finest beer please is Kathy Sparkle
fingers no it's not it's nobody that's
not my name Joe's work Oh like a bad guy
you really did the opposite of what a
superhero supposed to do you're him
you're the hero
you're welcome for not getting robbed
I want you basically 15
[Music]
yeah you electrocuted a bus and almost
kill these people and then I caught it
then leap tall buildings in a single
bound baby bad sad I'll choose you say
my name so my powers will become yours
[Music]
I'd like to purchase some of your finest
beer please Sam oler yes if you have a
location they're gonna cliff like a
castle ass type thing you're looking
some water splashing on rocks and stuff
then we will take that experience at an
IMAX
there's a foster couple outside mr.
Batson I can take care of myself give
these people a chance cuz that's what
they're giving you
Billy is a foster kid he's been in and
out of foster homes this is Billy Batson
he's a really good kid who wants the
best who sticks up for the other kid hey
man sorry about that and because he is
pure of hearts baby backs these
transports of this wizard
I choose you as chief you do and douse
him with his power of Shazam Shazam he
has this power of just saying one word
and turning into a superhero first goes
to see his friend Freddie you're the
only person I know that knows anything
about this caped crusaders now what are
your superpowers super powers dude I
don't even know how to pee in this thing
Freddie is superhero fanatic fishing we
find out that Billy is a superhero
because like I know exactly what to do
Freddie's like okay we have to test your
abilities and of course they're gonna
film it okay why are you talking I feel
like any kid who gains the power of
being and had your whole thinking like
you shouldn't do things that only adults
can do duh I'd like to purchase some of
your finest beer please that's his
actual vomit it's whisper fun waiting
Shazam is one of very few superhero
characters it is genuinely stoked to be
a superhero your phone charge your phone
charged help more often the night you've
got a character who is but grudgingly
pulled into this that everybody needs
them and like oh I have to save the
world again
Billy Batson is Stoke you're like a bad
guy right I just get to show up on set
and be like forget to do this I get to
fly around fight bad guys you're dead
[Music]
you've run from foster homes in six
counties I can't take care of myself
when you're 18 give these people a
chance because that's what they're
giving you
[Music]
this is billy batson make sure you make
him feel at home
they seem nice but don't buy it it gets
real Game of Thrones around here dude
just mess around you look at me and
you're like why so dark you're just able
to foster kid you've got it all Vince
you could have one superpower what would
you pick everybody chooses flight you
know why so they can fly away from this
conversation
no cuz heroes fly well you need your
fake family to stand up for you hey man
sorry about that
Billy Batson
I choose you
ask a peon
hello say my name so my powers may flow
through you but I don't know your names
through sure wait for you okay
Shazam
really you're the only person I know
that knows anything about this Cape
Crusader stuff tonight
it's crazy right
what are your superpowers super powers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing okay
why are you talking
no I'm gonna buff out your co-stars your
phone charge help like a bad guy right
you have full immunity from your dead
sorry about your window you're welcome
for not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero
[Music]